l'un des grands défis d'Allegiant
était de diviser le livre en deux films,
il suggère vraiment d'être divisé en
deux films différents en raison de l'
étendue de la fourniture, vous
ne voulez pas que le premier soit simplement une sorte
de surplace pour arriver au
deuxième mais vous ne voulez pas non plus
tout dévoiler dans le premier beaucoup de
conversations dans le développement de l'histoire
et où l'histoire s'est déroulée, quelles
sont les choses que nous voulons enregistrer pour
le prochain film et quelles sont les  les choses que nous
voulons traiter dans ce film,
vous savez, lorsque vous prenez un livre et le
divisez en deux films, vous voulez qu'il
soit terminé, suivez l'histoire
un pour un telle qu'elle était dans le livre était
franchement tout simplement impossible en raison de  le
film existant la façon dont l'histoire a
évolué donc il y a beaucoup de surprises à
venir ce n'est pas comme si vous alliez lire
Le Livre de la Légion et tout à coup
être bien je sais exactement ce qui se passe
il va y avoir des surprises à
bien des égards  il y a beaucoup de choses que Veronica
Roth a créées et puis il y a beaucoup de choses que
le réalisateur et les scénaristes et que
les autres personnes impliquées ont créées
Veronica nous ont donné beaucoup de latitude, elle a
essentiellement dit que j'avais écrit le livre, allez faire
le film, vous pensez que je peux voir
quelque chose  là-bas,
savez-vous que je ne suis peut-être pas un ange
McCarter, l'une des complexités de
l'adaptation était que depuis un haut
bâtiment à Chicago, vous seriez en
mesure de voir l'aéroport O'Hare où se trouve le
siège était incroyablement important
pour l'histoire qui  tous les habitants de
Chicago n'ont aucune idée qu'il y a un monde de
haute technologie à quelques kilomètres d'
eux pensez-vous vraiment que vous pouvez
empêcher les gens d'attendre les murs de la ville pendant
un verrouillage total mes soldats ont des ordres
personne ne sort
quand le gang étranger de Tristan s'est échappé de
Chicago  et passer par-dessus le mur et
traverser la frange et traverser cet
environnement vraiment désolé et désagréable ce
qu'ils réalisent, c'est que ce qu'ils ont
vu au-delà de la frange n'est qu'un
projet  ion et s'il n'y a rien d'
autre là-bas